es sind doch eigentlich nur lächerliche
1,5 grad auf die die erderwärmung
beschränkt werden soll doch die euphorie
von vor drei jahren als sich die welt in
paris auf genau dieses ziel geeinigt
hatte ist längst verflogen
dennoch ganz aufgegeben haben wir wollen
noch nicht eine art letztes aufbäumen
findet ab heute im polnischen kattowitz
stadt hier sollen die strengeren regeln
des pariser klima vertrages endgültig
beschlossen werden
doch die uhr tickt und der co2 ausstoß
geht weiter was wir vom bevorstehenden
klimagipfel kopf 24 kopf steht dabei für
conference of the parties erwarten
können und ob unsere erde überhaupt noch
zu retten ist jetzt bei pixum science
fiction hier gibt es jeden tag spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er kein video herzlich
willkommen schon wieder ein klimagipfel
werden sich jetzt vielleicht einige
denken einer von vielen am ende
wahrscheinlich doch eher nur wieder viel
gelaber ohne dass dabei etwas herum
kommt die ziele der teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer des treffens in kattowitz
sind tatsächlich aber ziemlich konkret
und zwar soll ein detailliertes
regelwerk beschlossen und antworten auf
konkrete technische und juristische
fragen zur umsetzung gefunden werden
welches land setzt welche maßnahmen um
und wie messen wir die erfolge in sachen
co2 ausstoß die welt klimakonferenz in
bonn im vergangenen jahr 2017 hat sie
die nötigen vorbereitungen dafür
getroffen in kattowitz soll jetzt eben
ein offizielles regelbuch dazu erstellt
werden denn damit können die zusagen der
einzelnen staaten in sachen klimaschutz
überprüft und verglichen werden die
teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen sollen
den text in kattowitz verabschieden
heißt also zusammengefasst die
verhandlungen die anfang dezember
staaten sind von extrem großer bedeutung
sie zeigen was die beschlüsse von paris
wert sind zudem wird es den sogenannten
thaller noah dialog geben in diesen eher
informellen gesprächsrunden geht es um
die nicht ausreichenden co2
minderungsziele von einzelnen ländern
doch größere ehrgeizigere ziele wird
sich wohl kaum ein land freiwillig
setzen erst in zwei jahren nämlich 2020
wird in sachen selbstverpflichtung
nachgerüstet und dass zudem freiwillig
klima forschungsteams rechnen mit harten
verhandlungen kattowitz und ein erfolg
des gipfels steht in den sternen die
gefahr
diskussionen und streitigkeiten ist groß
befürchtet beispielsweise die ehemalige
polnische diplomat in lidia war
frustrierend so lässt sich die aktuelle
lage also am besten zusammenfassen
das sagt auch johann rock strömen
direktor des potsdam instituts für
klimafolgenforschung pik
zitat wir hatten noch nie so viele
belege für die gefahren des klimawandels
wir sind in einer sehr ernsten situation
denn was ist von der uno klimakonferenz
vom vor drei jahren in paris geblieben
außer vielleicht ein paar schöne
erinnerungen damals sah es fast so aus
als hätte es die weltgemeinschaft doch
noch geschafft das ruder in sachen
klimaschutz umzureißen um 1,5 grad
sollte die erderwärmung möglichst
beschränkt werden doch seitdem ist viel
passiert immer mal wieder kommen klima
forschungsteams zu wort die sich
pessimistisch äussern das ziel sei nicht
mehr zu schaffen noch im oktober 2010
kam die schreckensnachricht nach dem
sonderbericht des intergovernmental
panel of climate change oft auch einfach
als weltklimarat bezeichnet sei die erde
schon jetzt um ein grad wärmer
nur wenn der co2 ausstoß bis 2050 auf
null gebracht werde könne man das 1,5
grad ziel noch erreichen dabei ist genau
das dringender als je zuvor
denn wenn die temperatur am um mehr als
1,5 grad steigt werden flach gelegene
insel staten geflutet so die befürchtung
hatten wir ja auch gerade mit einer
überspülten insel wir haben hier ja
darüber berichtet heißt also es muss
jetzt etwas passieren denn die uhr tickt
worauf wollen wir noch warten der
meeresspiegel steigt die antarktis
schmilzt es gibt immer mehr dürren und
auch hier bei uns werden die
wetterphänomene immer extremer wenn wir
nichts ändern wird die temperatur in der
antarktis bis zum jahr 2070 um krasse
drei grad ansteigen und das hätte
katastrophale folgen für uns alle dazu
patricia espinosa die chefin des un
klimasekretariats anfang september
wir wissen dass diese extreme ereignisse
nicht verschwinden werden sie werden
immer schlimmer werden leider heißt also
der klimawandel ist real und da das
beweisen jetzt aktuell auch die
waldbrände in kalifornien die zahlreiche
tote gefordert haben und schäden in
milliardenhöhe hinterlassen haben und
bei diesem ganzen schrecken dürfen wir
eines nicht vergessen er ist zum größten
teil menschen gemacht wir haben es jetzt
in unseren händen
die unsere welt in einigen jahren
aussehen wird das ist wirklich eine
große verantwortung der wir uns stellen
müssen dazu hans otto pörtner vom alfred
wegener institut im jahr 2014
wir müssen uns klar darüber werden dass
wir heute noch entscheidung optionen
haben dass wir ein zeitfenster haben
vielleicht von 20 jahren in dem wir
darüber befinden wie nachfolgende
generationen das klima auf dieser erde
erleben werden
doch der zusammenhalt der welt in sachen
klimaschutz sieht grausig aus erst ist
der us-präsident donald trump aus dem
vertrag ausgestiegen
zudem leugnet er bei seinem besuch in
kalifornien den klimawandel weiter
obwohl sich die seit monaten anhaltende
trockenheit sehr wohl mit dem
klimawandel erklären lässt demnächst
könnte sich vielleicht auch brasilien
zurückziehen
denn der neue präsident dort hält den
klima und umweltschutz für eher
unwichtig und so scheint es so als hätte
nur ein teil der erde den wettlauf gegen
die zeit aufgenommen das bittere dabei
der co2 ausstoß geht weiter und global
gesehen wird er wohl beispielsweise in
diesem jahr sogar noch steigen
die forschungsteams vom bka gehen davon
aus dass die emissionen der menschen im
jahr 2018 um insgesamt 2 prozent
ansteigen werden neubauprojekte von
kohlekraftwerken in indonesien ägypten
und pakistan seien einer der gründe
dafür
und vielleicht ist das eine der
zentralen herausforderungen in dieser
zeit diejenigen ins boot zu holen die
den kampf gegen den klimawandel als
unbedeutend abstempeln denn klar ist
auch europa allein kann nicht retter des
globalen klimas sein zumindest aber
vielleicht vorreiter doch dabei reicht
es nicht sich zurückzulehnen und auf
andere zu zeigen auch deutschland hat
versagt im gegensatz zu schweden wir
haben darüber berichtet das
skandinavische land liegt in dem ranking
der europäischen
nichtregierungsorganisationen can auf
platz eins und zwar mit 77 der von ken
geforderten maßnahmen bei der can
bewertung ging es darum inwieweit die
länder bezüglich des ausbaus der
erneuerbaren energien sind und wie sich
die pro-kopf-emissionen entwickelt haben
erst auf platz sieben kommt dann
deutschland kurz vor litauen und
kroatien beispielsweise weit abgehängt
also und tatsächlich schon im
klimaschutzbericht von 2017 hatte das
umweltministerium zugegeben seine ziele
für 2020 nicht zu erreichen
bis dahin
wenn man beispielsweise den ausstoß von
treibhausgasen nur um rund 30 prozent
reduzieren können
eigentlich war eine reduktion um 40
prozent angepeilt das ist nicht einmal
35 prozent werden war eine riesige
enttäuschung und so fordert nicht nur
die organisation für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung oecd die
deutsche politik dazu auf intensiv und
hart gegen die schlechte klimabilanz des
landes vorzugehen die oecd bezieht sich
dabei beispielsweise auf den
kohle-ausstieg hier ist deutschland in
der rolle des größten braunkohle
förderers weltweit das fazit ist also
mehr als bitter wenn wir schlittern
nicht einfach so in die nächste eiszeit
weil die erde das nur mal so mit uns
vorhat wir stürzen die erde durch unser
verhalten ins verderben das positive
daran
wir können auch unser verhalten ändern
und an vielen stellschrauben drehen denn
dann könnten wir unsere erde vielleicht
noch retten wir werden hier immer wieder
über den klimawandel berichten wenn er
kein video zu diesem thema in zukunft
und zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollen dann abonniert auch clixoom auf
englisch denn auch da gibt es immer
videopremieren dafür einfach hier
klicken und hier drunter geht's weiter
mit ice age in europe world stream kam
touristenziel
bis bald hoffentlich auf dem englischen
kanal zu tun
stay tuned